elden ring is coming to game boy sorta
and the reveal of modern warfare 2 could
be sooner than you think
reddit user shintendo announced a d make
of elden ring on the game's subreddit
and even posted a clip of the opening
area in boss fight shintendo revealed
they intend to show how they develop
elden ring for actual game boy hardware
on twitch and archive it on their
youtube channel shindendo also clarified
that they are using software called gb
studio 3.0 to accomplish the enormous
feat due to that enormity they are also
not settled on the scope of the project
yet but did say they're at least hoping
to finish the limgrave area by the end
of may if and when that section is
complete shin plans to release a demo on
itch.io until then you all have to
settle for the actual elden ring which
we gave a perfect score to and i still
haven't beat yet so we've established
that elden ring on gameboy would be cool
but i'd love to see call of duty as well
and speaking of cod infinity ward's
social media pages have gone dark in an
apparent viral marketing campaign to
promote this year's call of duty modern
warfare 2. as ign discovered brightening
the new image seems to show the mask of
simon ghost riley a famous character
from the modern warfare universe modern
warfare 2 was originally announced in
february alongside the reveal of a new
warzone title today activision blizzard
management shared a little more about
both projects confirming that modern
warfare 2 is the most quote advanced
entry in the series so far activision
also boasts that war zone 2 or whatever
the game is called will feature quote
groundbreaking innovations in the past
developers have admitted it's been a
struggle to adapt warzone from modern
warfare 2019 to cold war and then
vanguard and more recently they couldn't
do map rotation because of the file size
so this new version could be a chance to
start fresh and pull off map changes and
events more similar to fortnite and apex
are you excited for modern warfare 2
because i definitely am so hit the
comments and predict when the official
reveal will drop not into shooters
that's okay because diablo immortal is
set to launch on both ios and android on
june 2nd the game will release with 8
different zones each with their own
style loot and enemies with more zones
coming in the future players can also
join in random live events to take on
larger enemies as well as an eight
person mission that serves as the game's
first raid experience june 2nd will also
mark the beginning of an open beta test
for the newly revealed pc version of the
game which will support full cross
progression with both ios and android
the pc version will support wasd
movement for the first time in diablo
history while all progress made by pc
beta testers will carry over to the full
version of the game upon release diablo
immortal is a unique story in diablo
lore set between diablo 2 and 3. those
interested in pre-registering can do so
on both ios and android right now so
without saying mobile sucks comment your
favorite thing to play on your phone you
can follow me on twitter at devante
chisholm and i'll see you again tomorrow